im mai gibt es im garten richtig viel zu
tun deswegen schnappen wird unsere
gummistiefel und schauen uns mal an
welche aufgaben mai richtig richtig
wichtig sind
[Musik]
immer ist es ja oft schon viel wärmer
als vorher und das bedeutet zum einen
natürlich dass unsere pflanzen ganz zu
wachsen aber zum anderen natürlich auch
dass die schädlinge wie zum beispiel
schnecken wieder viel aktiver werden ich
hab's im april video schon gesagt
deswegen jetzt hier nur eine kurze
erinnerung schützt eure pflanzen vor
schnecken schütz teuren kohl auch wenn
ihr ihn draußen an bord mit kultur
schutz netzen vor dem col weißling und
der weißen fliege das ist einfach super
wichtig dass sie da jetzt dran denn ich
lasse abgeblühte blütenstände vom
letzten jahr ganz gerne bis in den mai
reihen stehen weil daher auch insekten
überwintern
aber jetzt wo es wärmer wird können wir
die auch abschneiden und ein bisschen in
unseren gärten aufräumen und das machen
wir jetzt mal
ernst sträucher wie zum beispiel
himbeeren oder auch johannisbeeren oder
stachelbeeren justieren die wollen sich
jetzt über eine dünger gabe damit sie
dann noch ordentlich bären produzieren
und außerdem verteile ich jetzt auch
ganz gerne muss zwischen
beerensträuchern und gibt denen auch
noch eine ladung kommt die jungpflanzen
brauchen jetzt natürlich auch viel
aufmerksamkeit das ist sowohl an der
zeit wieder neue jungpflanzen im haus
vorzuziehen damit ihr dann auch rund ums
jahr ernten könnt als auch die stark
zähler unter ihren jungen pflänzchen
also zb den ganzen kohl oder auch die
tomaten die jetzt vielleicht noch im
haus stehen mit einem biologischen
flüssigdünger über das gießwasser zu
düngen weil die anzuchterde die man zu
jungpflanzen an sucht ja oft verwendet
wer ganz nährstoffarm ist das ist auch
extra so damit die jungpflanzen erstmal
schön ordentlich wurzeln bilden aber
dann finden die natürlich nicht genug zu
essen und deswegen die starke und
mittels cera bei der anzucht jetzt auf
jeden fall noch zu denken und dann müsst
ihr die natürlich auch abhärten bevor
die nach draußen ins beet umziehen
können dafür fand die eine woche vor dem
auspflanzen an und gewöhnt die langsam
ein bisschen an das sonnenlicht weil
wenn die drinnen aufgewachsen sind dann
haben wir ja noch nie täglich
sonnenlicht abbekommen und dann können
die ganz schnell einen sonnenbrand
bekommen und gehen dann einfach ein das
ist richtig durch deswegen stellt sie
erst mal ein bisschen in den schatten am
ersten tag und dann wieder ins haus in
den städten sie am zweiten tag
vielleicht mal kurz in die sonne dann
wieder in den schatten dann wieder ins
haus und so gewöhnt ihr sie schritt für
schritt daran dass sie dann nach einer
woche wirklich gewappnet sind für das
abenteuerliche leben draußen im beet
wusstet ihr dass sie aus bremischer in
euren eigenen dünger herstellen könnt
dafür einfach einen eimer voll
brennesseln pflücken mit wasser
auffüllen und am besten noch eine
handvoll gesteinsmehl reingeben damit
dass die unangenehmen gerüche
unterdrückt und dann jeden tag umrühren
natürlich abdecken das kleine insekten
rein fallen und wenn die brennesseln
schön braun geworden sind dann könnt ihr
die blätter einfach herausfiltern
eure dann verdient als dünger für eure
stark zähler und mediziner verwenden
denkt daran das ist immer schon mal die
ein oder andere trockenperiode geben
kann ihre pflanzen aber oft noch ganz
klein sind und deswegen noch vom wetter
abhängig also nicht vergessen wenn ihr
gerade was ausgewählt habt oder
jungpflanzen ins beet gesetzt habt dass
ihr dann den boden in den nächsten
wochen immer schwingt haltet
und dann habe ich ein paprika tipp für
euch und zwar gegen die paprika pflanzen
oft hier oben in der mitte seine
allererste blüte aus im mai und bei
meiner ist es noch nicht so weit aber
die kommt bestimmt wir finden wir auch
im april aber das ist ganz wichtig dass
man diese allererste königs blüte heißt
die ausbricht weil die paprika pflanze
sonst all ihre kraft in diese erste
frucht steckt und nicht in die eigenes
wachstum das ist aber wichtig dass die
pflanze erst mal ein bisschen größer
wird bevor sie dann auch früchte trägt
deswegen die erste blüte vielleicht auch
die ersten zwei drei blüten einfach
ausbrechen dann habt ihr hinterher eine
größere ernte von euren patrick ablassen
der mai ist auch der monat in dem ich
mit dem männchen anfangen und zwar
verteidigt da jetzt zum alle pflanzen
diese ungefähr 10 15 cm groß sind eine
schicht aus organischem material ich
nehme da für holzhackschnitzel manchmal
auch rasenschnitt wenn dir anfällt die
holzhackschnitzel haben den vorteil dass
man eben auch schnecken ab wert weil die
da nicht so gerne drüber kriechen über
anderen materialien und wenn dann
richtung sommer die pflanzen noch ein
bisschen größer werden dann könnt ihr
die mulchschicht ruhig nochmal erhöhen
so dass der mich richtig schön unkraut
unterdrückt und auch das wasser im boden
hält so dass ihr viel weniger gießen
müssen seht ihr wie viel besser im
frühbeet kasten alles wächst es ist
jetzt aber langsam bis hin zu wahren da
drin für unsere gemüsepflanzen und
außerdem stoßen die auch alle schon oben
an so dass sie jetzt ganz krumm weiter
wachsen und deswegen ist es immer an der
zeit dass wir den freeway kasten
abnehmen im keller verstaut und dann
kann der im september oktober wieder auf
die hochbeete draufgeschraubt werden
wisst ihr was das ist gemüsepflanzen
sehen oft ganz anders aus wenn sie babys
machen wollen und in die blüte gehen das
ist grünkohl der es hier für die
saatgutvermehrung daneben steht noch
wirsing dem ich auch saatgut ziehen
wenn ihr euch meinen euren garten
umschaut und die im winter vielleicht
auch schon gemüse angebaut habt dann
seht ihr jetzt dass einige gemüse wie
zum beispiel der feldsalat oder manchmal
auch schon der spinat als langsam
anfangen zu blühen und das ist total
schön wenn man so sein eigenes sagt
entnehmen kann und weil das so ein
wichtiges thema ist das kurhaus
gärtnerin und haus gärtner unabhängiger
werden von den großen saatgutkonzernen
dass wir das wissen erhalten wie man
sagen weiter vermehrt und das auch
wahnsinnig viel spaß macht habe ich mich
mit luzie von drei schläge zusammengetan
sie ist eine von meinen mitarbeiterinnen
die arbeitet also der wurzelwerk aber
die hat eben auch einen saatgutbetrieb
wo sie eigenes saatgut herstellt und
deswegen auch wahnsinnig viel ahnung von
dem thema und sie hat ein e book
geschrieben und das verleger ich euch
gerne unten in der video beschreibung
das kennt ihr euch gerne holen und dann
wisst ihr von anfang bis ende für
anfänger erklärt wie man sein eigenes
saatgut r zeigt also ganz viel spaß
damit seht ihr diese pflänzchen hier das
ist die rote beete durchgesetzt habe die
es ganz vereinzelt aufgegangen an
anderen stellen überhaupt nicht und
deswegen vereinzelt ich die jetzt das
muss ja nicht auf einer stelle müssen ja
nicht ganz viele pflanzen wachsen haben
die ja gar nicht genug platz wenn man
jede pflanze braucht einfach so 10 15 cm
abstand und was mache ich jetzt ein
pflänzchen
[Musik]
der mai ist der beste monat um
kartoffeln zu pflanzen und da gibt es
eine richtig tolle pflanzt technik mit
der man auf einer wiese ohne viel arbeit
neue beete anlegen kann und trotzdem
noch eine menge kartoffeln erntet wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie das funktioniert
dann schaut gerne da vorbei ansonsten
werden jetzt auch noch ganz viele andere
gemüse aus gesät und gepflanzt welche
das sind zeige ich euch da drüben und
dann geht raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag um 10 für ein neues
video macht's gut